[Applause]  now they take their time shot clock is  out of three man fleet on the drive went  to the left hand  so nice getting the big fella on your  right shoulder having him think he's  gonna block it  using the rim as your protector going up  and under knocking it down vanvleet  nice play oh man when you think  of the smaller guys they have to have so  much heart they're in and out their  attack going up with the right side to  left  off the glass over the reigning  in the defensive player of the year  beautiful  of the game presented by degree  oh man so smooth and look at alice's  brother right there  oh man he said don't do that to my  brother you got your luck